where we're going to head to next is not
the question of my all now you're going
to revenues how they relate to each
other but what if you want to climb out
off like I want to do more than just how
things are changing I want to know what
things are I have to kill a poison
spider okay so that would be a little
bit like translating from okay well how
quickly by moving around this circle to
thinking about well where am I on the
circle at given points okay and in order
to clear back out of derivatives we know
that integration is the calculus Taylor
we know so I rushed old enough for you
when you have a look at question 1 you
see how this requires us choose
integration here's the scenario
really what is flowing out of tank at
the rate of D vo DT equals 5/2 t minus
50 pause in fact maybe you want to even
draw a little diagram if you have
I take a water right that's Warren Baker
what is flowing cut of this tank and
they give us an equation that defines DV
or DT so that's how the volume is
changing over time so this is the flow
rate out of the tank
they're giving us this that's how volume
is uh is changing your over time okay so
what you have a look at this for
instance and we'll actually get into
this in a second at a time like say time
zero right at the beginning what's this
going to be equal to
how about good the two T is going to
become zero so you've got five times
negative 50 so five times 30 50 is
negative 250 so this thing is the volume
so it's a bit of a dodgy V the volume is
getting smaller at the first instance at
negative 250 what unit are they it's in
liters per minute liters per minute okay
so this is so this is coming a button
you can see this is going to change
right for example at a certain point and
I'm like going to say it just yet
because this is gonna be one of the
questions at a certain point this
expression will be zero
do you notice that that means that the
volume is no longer changing so the
water it starts coming out this melon
liter per minute but it seems to be
slowing down eventually it stops so
you've got a picture in your head for
how the quantity is changing and the
rate at which it changes is also
changing so it's not like that on that
point those moving around at a constant
speed the whole time what is coming out
but it's slowing down as it progresses
okay so this is the scenario and again
we're dealing with liters per minute
here's Part A this is the question I
refuse to answer
when does the water stop flying so my
advice for all of these questions I mean
I've been saying this from the beginning
even when we went in this topic is
please use words these use words explain
what's going on don't just have a series
of disconnected equations so I'm
literally going to say the water stops
flowing when now what does it mean for
the waters stopped flowing well that
means what can we say about the volume
at that time yeah interesting we I don't
have an expression for volume at them I
will get one shortly but I don't have an
expression for the volume but I do have
an expression for how the volume is
changing okay and we saw the machine
well of course the one will stop flowing
when the container is empty but maybe
the water stops flowing before then I
don't actually know that yes okay so
this one is just stops flowing doesn't
make sure to limit volume it tells you
about how the volume is changing in
other words it's not changing anymore
because it's not forming anymore does
that make sense okay so we're kind of
like going to another step saying oh
well volume zero sure you're a be empty
but maybe not I mean this is
on your diagram well have a look at this
right look at where this spout is the
volume will still have there will still
be something in there on my diagram once
the worst subside cuz look no more get
out right so it's not hard to think of a
scenario where the water stuff flowing
before the volume is zeros don't assume
that that's the condition all I know is
about continually tape so I'm going to
say that okay at this point the volume
water stops changing and that's what
water flowing would mean okay so now I
could go ahead and solve this
in other words five times this equals
zero and don't skip on that step don't
know you go ahead and even take out a
factor of five I know it's easy to do
but we want to say that I understand
what DVD he is and we're gonna go
straight to the direct substitution from
there I think it is you know now I can
actually just read off what family of T
will make good and don't forget we've
been solving this for like all these
letters and that kind of thing but the
question itself says like the questions
are the same soul fatigue weight and DV
l dt equals zero the question says when
does the water stop flowing so this for
the point I'm going to say therefore
after like the water stops flowing when
after 25 minutes I bring my unity okay
so again don't skimp on the words the
words are what is communicating your ass
any other question